(audience cheers and claps)
- Is this, like-
They were very excited.
Is this like, when you go to Target,
does this just happen when you enter?
- What's Target?
- What?
- I'm just kidding.
- I love Target.
- I'm kidding. I was kidding.
- You go in for one thing
- I love Target.
- and leave with 50 that you don't need.
Yes.
- Always, always.
- Yes. Your birthday is tomorrow, right?
So what do you do for your birthday?
Do you go big or do you chill?
- I'm gonna be playing a show.
- Oh, you go big.
- In New York.
- Yeah. I played a show my last birthday.
- Yeah.
It's so fun to do that.
Is it like a big release thing?
- It's just the way the
schedule worked out.
But I don't know.
I'm not like, huge on my birthdays.
- Yeah.
- And to be honest,
I actually couldn't think
of anything more fun to do
than to share, you know,
my music with my fans and-
- And your band.
Your band is incredible.
(audience cheers)
Like, I seen you,
I've seen you a few times live,
and you're incredible.
It's an incredibly
- Thank you.
- physical show.
I love how much you incorporate your band.
Like you really highlight them.
Singers, not everybody.
And it's a really cool thing to go.
You get to see him live,
but then also he showcases
these incredible musicians
you share a stage with.
- They are so good.
Yeah, they're so good.
It's, they're like family to me now.
I mean, we've toured for
a long time together.
A lot of 'em.
- Yeah.
- And music to me, one of
the most valuable things that
you can experience in
music is collaboration.
- Yeah.
- And sharing the stage
with such amazing musicians,
it would be a travesty
to not showcase them.
- Yeah, no, I agree.
- So.
- I feel the same way about my crew.
They're so gifted and I don't know-
- That walkout music got me right.
- Yes.
(audience claps)
- So you recently
performed in your hometown.
So like, when you do a show,
'cause you've had so many hits
or so many things people
wanna hear you sing.
But is there one that
you'd still love doing?
Like, is there a favorite song of yours?
- Well, in reference to
Memphis playing the show there.
That was the first time
we played "Selfish."
- So that made that special.
- You were there?
- I was there.
- Oh my gosh.
- I flew there without
having tickets and I got in.
- [Kelly] Oh my God. No way.
- Wow.
- I still had a bracelet on.
- [Justin] Oh my gosh. What?
- Yeah. I, when I found
out you were performing,
I literally booked the
flight, booked hotels,
not knowing I was getting in.
- And that's why we have careers. (claps)
Thank you. (claps)
- And I literally-
(all clapping)
I live in Jersey.
- Did you have a good time?
- I, amazing time.
I still have the bracelet on.
I can't take myself to end.
- I love it.
- [Justin] Wonderful.
- I found out I was coming here yesterday.
- Did you know he was
gonna drop the new single?
- Yes. I, mean,
- Oh, okay, okay.
all the subliminal messaging
on your, you know, your TikTok.
We, you know,
we try to figure it out.
- Little Easter eggs.
I like it. I like it.
- This is fun.
- (laughs) We're like CIA agents, but yes.
I, it was unbelievable.
And I can't wait to-
- Well, as we say in
Memphis, thanks for coming.
- Thanks for coming.
(all laugh)
- [Audience Member] Unbelievable.
I'll do it all over again.
- Come on back anytime you want.
(Audience laughs)
- Well, so you did the
new song there, "Selfish,"
but what's like one of your favorite,
like I always still love
- From the catalog.
- doing "Miss Independent."
Yeah, like, I always love
- Yes.
- doing that song.
- You love doing
"Miss Independent?"
- It's my first single
and I don't know why
I love it live. I love it Live.
(audience cheers and claps)
- What is, do you have a favorite?
- I mean, "Rock Your Body's" fun still.
♪ Rock your body ♪
- Yeah, I like that one.
- "Mirrors."
"Mirrors" is still fun to sing.
(audience whoops)
Although sometimes I'm like,
why did I write this in this key?
It's very high.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] That's what I say a lot.
- Yeah.
- Because in the studio it's-
- That's why I don't go
on stage until like 9:00 PM. (laughs)
- Yeah. You're ah, isn't
there yet? (laughs)
- It's not there yet.
It's not there yet.
- What do you, this is a real question.
- What a great impersonation
by the way. (laughs)
- (laughs) I was trying to do my falsetto.
- It was great.
- In my head voice
and I was like, "Don't suck."
- I enjoyed it.
- So, thank you.
What do you have left to conquer?
'Cause we have worked
together in the studio.
And by the way, I think
because of your background,
and how much you are so good at harmony,
and I loved how you recorded me,
and I loved all your ideas,
and the freedom you give singers.
You're a really great producer.
- Are you just saying
that because I'm here?
- No. No. I know I've
said this when you're not-
I was like, he actually
makes her a great producer.
'Cause I don't find that I'm
good at producing like that.
But I love singing.
But you produce, you write songs, you act,
you do all the things.
Is there anything left?
You've had such an illustrious career.
Like is there anything
left that you wanna do
that you haven't done yet?
- Well, first of all, that was very kind.
- [Kelly] It was honest.
- I growing up in the industry
and getting access to
so much in the studio.
- Yeah.
- I just became
like a studio rat.
Like, I just loved being in there,
and I love the creative process,
and, you know, and also as
it pertains to harmonies,
I spent some time with four other guys
doing a lot of harmonies.
(audience cheering)
- Well, who are you speaking of? (laughs)
And uh-
- By the way,
y'all broke the internet
when y'all came back for the song.
- Yeah, that was fun. That was fun.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It was kinda crazy.
Like there's so much
that just picks up right
where it left off as far as the chemistry,
but, yeah, it was-
- That's fun.
(audience cheers)
- Yes.
- I'm just saying.
- I don't normally, I
don't want people to think,
can what is that?
Can you see that picture again?
I don't, I feel like I have to disclaimer.
Like I was having a
really bad allergy day,
and that's why I was
wearing the sunglasses.
I don't want...
(audience laughs)
No. But yeah, we've been in the studio,
so there may be a little something.
- Okay, that's what I was
gonna ask.
- Something in the future too.
- Okay. Yeah.
(audience cheers)
- It's exciting. It's exciting.
His new album is called
"Everything I Thought it Was."
It's out now.
(audience cheers)
I've been to your performances,
I was talking about earlier,
and you're, it's a very physical show.
- It is.
- You have to be exhausted
at the end of it.
- I am.
- Yeah.
I am not that kind of exhausted
after my show. (laughs)
I'm like, "Walk to the right.
Walk to the left." (laughs)
- I'll tell you though, like I actually,
when I come off stage,
I'm so amped from that.
Like, I have trouble going to sleep.
- Me too.
- You know?
- Yeah. That's why I like
to go on earlier. (laughs)
Then I can finally go to bed.
- You might be onto to something.
- I'm like.
- We should, yeah.
I'm gonna think about this.
- I'm just saying.
So your new album, so it's called,
"Everything I Thought it
Was," that's the title.
So what did you think it was? (laughs)
- (laughs) Yeah, I'm still
trying to figure that out.
- Yeah.
- It's interesting,
I never sort of with song
titles when I'm writing a song,
I never know what the song title is,
it's sort of until I finish the song.
And that sort of applies with albums.
I would play, I started working
on this album over the Pandemic,
and I ended up with about, I don't know,
close to a hundred songs.
- Yeah.
- And narrowed them down to 18.
- Which is hard.
- And, which was hard to do,
but when I started
piecing the album together
and picking my favorites,
I would play it for people close to me,
and they would say, "Oh, this sounds like,
this sounds like every part of you,
of every album mixed into
- Oh, that's cool.
- one album.
- Like an amalgamation
of all of it, yeah.
- Yeah.
And having this moment in my life,
and sort of looking back on
everything that it's been,
and I think, you know,
sort of accepting all of it
and being excited about all of it.
Learning from all of it, applying that
to moving forward in your life.
- Good and the bad. Yeah.
- Yeah. The good, the
bad, the fast, the slow.
I think you get to this
point where you sort of
you arrive at peace with all of that.
And there's also a couple
of songs that bookend
the album that are a
little more introspective.
And the last line of the first
song on the album, you know,
I say, "I'm everything I thought I was,
I'm everything you thought I was,
I'm everything I thought I was,
it was everything I thought it was."
- Oh, I like that.
- And, you know, it's just
about arriving at this place
right now in my life as
an artist, as a husband,
as a father, as a human.
And I'm just really excited
about what the future holds.
- I think that's a cool thing
about being an artist in
whatever form you are an artist.
It's such a blessing to have
that outlet first of all
for therapy reasons alone.
- For sure.
- Yeah. But then also it's ever changing.
Like, we don't, it's not a monotonous job.
You don't come in, you
know what I'm saying?
Every album's different.
Every part chapter of
your life is different.
It inspires something different.
- Absolutely.
- I think that's rad.
- We're very lucky.
- We are. We are.
- Yeah, I agree.
Well Justin teased the album
as E-I-T-I-W on Instagram,
and people started guessing what it meant.
- I was gonna go with E-I-E-I-O, but...
- (laughs) Well this is pretty great.
Someone said it stands for,
"Every time I twerk I win."
Which kind of, kind of you do.
- I mean-
- If you're able to twerk.
I mean, it's a good day.
"Everyone in Texas is winning."
That's my personal favorite
for obvious reasons.
Yeah.
"Everyone is totally into werewolves."
(audience laughs)
Yeah, I'm into werewolves.
- That's a choice.
- I'm into Wolverine, I'm into that.
- I mean, every time I twerk I win.
I mean, that's...
- Pretty great.
- I also do wanna explain
the trailer though,
'cause it it's Benicio Del Toro, right?
That's the voice.
- Yes, yes.
- Like the narrator.
What's, what here, let's
play it real quick.
(screen image whooshing)
- [Benicio Del Toro] What do we have here?
(car engine revving)
Ooh, that's a nice car.
Wait, it's a model.
Did that say JT?
Okay, that sunset is definitely not real.
Ah, there is Justin.
Why wouldn't he turn around?
What the (beep) is he staring at?
(dramatic musical tone)
(audience cheers and claps)
- The best.
(Justin clapping)
- What's going on there?
Is it gonna unfold what's happening there?
- Was that not the greatest voice?
- Yes.
- Of all time.
- [Kelly] The greatest last line.
- He is just one of my favorite people.
I had the fortune of,
the last film that I did,
called "Reptile."
We worked together,
and he's just the best.
- Yeah, the fact that
he said yes, he's like,
"Yeah, I got this." Yeah.
- I literally, I called him.
We have the same manager,
and we became friends a while ago.
And then we ended up working together
and I just, we were,
we had shot the footage
and we were thinking about
who would be the voice.
And I was like, "Oh, Benicio."
And so he was, we called him
and he's so funny. (laughs)
He's like, "I only do
pushups for you, bro."
(audience laughs)
- Pushups for you.(laughs)
- Yeah.
- I do pushups for no one.
But he's the best,
and such a good friend.
And I was-
- Yeah.
- I can't wait to see-
- He's like my favorite part
of the whole process right now. (laughs)
- I love it.
Well, I mentioned this single,
the first single is "Selfish."
So Justin sings, "If I get
jealous, I can't help it.
I want every bit of you,
I guess I'm selfish.
It's bad for my mental,
but I can't fight it."
That's a very sexy lyric, man.
(Justin smacks lips)
Yeah, you want every bit?
(Kelly imitates eating)
(audience laughs)
- All of it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I love that.
What is it-
- All of it.
- What did you, okay, okay, okay.
(Kelly laughs and claps)
(Justin laughs)
(audience screams)
You're gonna have to buy the album,
to figure out all the meanings.
But I, no, I love a lyric that
kind of leaves it open too.
Like it's, you know what I'm saying?
I think that's very, it's enticing.
- I had gone to one of my friends,
who's also my music director on tour,
Adam Blackstone.
- Yeah.
- Who is fantastic.
- Amazing.
- Yes. (claps)
- Yeah.
- And he was doing these jazz nights
at a small spot in LA
and he asked me to come,
and I did a cover of a cover,
which was Donny Hathaway's version
of John Lennon's "Jealous Guy."
And I came back to the studio after that
and there was something in the air about
just the lyrical content of that,
and sort of what John
Lennon wrote about being,
about just humbling
himself to the fact that
he has those types of emotions.
- Yeah.
- And I just felt really inspired
by sort of that sentiment.
- Yeah. I love the song.
- It's also like one of those things
that even though it's a natural emotion,
you know, not feeling shame
about having natural emotions
and talking about that with
your significant other.
- Yeah.
- It's sort of like-
- Which is not generally
taught in the south, especially for boys.
So that's really cool
- It's not.
- that you're open about that.
That's awesome. Yeah.
- It's not. It's not.
And, but I-
- All the feelings are valid.
- They are.
- Yeah.
- And I think that's
the sexiest thing ever
is when you have that
communication with your partner.
And you could talk about
any and everything.
- Yeah.
- Oh, absolutely.
♪ One day ♪
Let's do another short commercial break.
(audience laughs)
Justin's new album is called,
"Everything I Thought It Was." (laughs)
- I'll see you guys later. (laughs)
- The first single is called "Selfish."
Check them out.